BE ON TONIGHT'S RADICAL 2020
DEMOCRATS ARE BATTLING IT OUT IN
THE GREAT STATE OF OHIO.
WE SENT LAWRENCE JONES TO THE
BUCKEYE STATE TO FIND OUT WHAT
LOCALS THINK OF THE SCANDAL
PLAYING DEMOCRATIC FRONT RUNNER
JOE AND HIS SON HUNTER WHO HAD A
DISASTROUS APPEARANCE THIS
MORNING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BIDEN IS THE FRONT RUNNER.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE HUNTER
BIDEN SCANDAL THAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW?
>> THAT IS SO SIGNIFICANT IN
THAT THEY ARE ALL TALKING ABOUT
DONALD AND UKRAINE.
THEY REALLY SHOULD BE LOOKING,
AND THEY ARE, AT HUNTER.
>> THE WHOLE IDEA ABOUT UKRAINE
AND HUNTER AND ALL OF THAT, THAT
IS SIMPLY POLITICS.
THAT'S PEOPLE DIGGING UP STUFF
ABOUT EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> I CERTAINLY HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT ALL THIS HAPPENING WITH
REGARDS TO BIDEN END OF THE
UKRAINE AND ALL OF THAT.
>> DOESN'T BOTHER ME.
I DON'T THINK IT'S UNIQUE IN OUR
COUNTRY WHATSOEVER.
CURRENT COLLOQUIAL ENVIRONMENT.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HUNTER BIDEN --
>> NO.
I THINK HUNTER BIDEN SAID HIS
STORY, TOLD HIS STORY.
>> IT'S LIKE A PAY TO PLAY TYPE
OF THING.
HE SOLD HIS NAME.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T THINK HE
WOULD'VE GOTTEN THAT JOB IF HE
DIDN'T HAVE THE LAST NAME BIDEN?
>> COME ON NOW.
>> BIDEN SAYS HE DOESN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT.
>> PROBABLY NOT.
>> BIDEN SAID HE DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT.
>> YEAH RIGHT.
HE SAID HE DIDN'T TALK TO HIS
SON ABOUT IT ALSO.
WHO BELIEVES THAT?
>> Sean: NOBODY.
APPARENTLY DEMOCRATIC VOTERS ARE
NOT HAPPY WITH THEIR
PRESIDENTIAL CHOICES EITHER.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG IS NOW
RECONSIDERING A RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AND IN A NEW POLL OUT
OF NEW HAMPSHIRE, FORMER
FIRST LADY MICHELLE OBAMA
ENTERED THE RACE, SHE WOULD BE
THE FRONT RUNNER WITH BIDEN AND
WARREN TRAILING BEHIND HER.
IT NEW PRODUCTIVE MODELS BY
MOODY'S ANALYTICS, TROUT LOOKS
LIKELY TO GET THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE VOTES NEEDED TO WIN
REELECTION IN 2020.
YES, CONGRESSMAN AL GREEN IS
RIGHT.
WE BETTER IMPEACHMENT BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BEAT HIM.
DURING HIS NOW IT'S FOX NEWS
SPECIAL HANNITY 2020 ON THE ROAD
CORRESPONDENT AND INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER, LAWRENCE JONES.
AND MICHAEL BASS, LAW PRESIDENT,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF RUNS PREVIOUS.
THEY KIND OF SEE THE REALITY
ABOUT THE BIDEN'S I MISSING THA
THAT.
>> YES, A LOT OF INDEPENDENCE
AND FORMER DEMOCRATS DID END UP
GOING FOR TRON.
THE INTERESTING THING I NOTICED
THERE IS THE PEOPLE, IF THEY
WERE IN THE BIDEN CAM, THEY WERE
VERY DEFENSIVE'S OF HIM.
IT BUT IF THEY WERE ALREADY
GOING FOR OTHER DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES, THEY WERE VERY
INTERESTED IN WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WITH THE HUNTER BIDEN THING AND
IF THERE WAS GOING TO BE AN
INVESTIGATION OF IT.
IT'S THE ONE THING THAT IS SO
CONCERNING THOUGH IS ALTHOUGH
THE SUPPORTERS OF THE OTHER
CANDIDATES SEE IT AS AN ISSUE,
NONE OF THE CANDIDATES ON THE
DEBATE STAGE RIGHT NOW ARE
WILLING TO GO AFTER JOE BIDEN.
ALL OF US KNOW THAT IT'S SHADY,
EVEN THE OTHER CANDIDATES
SUPPORTED, BUT NONE OF THEM WANT
TO CALL HIM ON IT.
>> Sean: WE ARE LOOKING AT A
CALENDAR, AND IF ANYONE ELSE
WANTS TO JUMP INTO THE RADICAL
POLLS, REINCE PRIEBUS COME OF
THAT DEADLINE IS COMING UP VERY
SHORTLY.
>> GOOD POINT SEAN.
THE DEADLINES -- FOR EVERY
CANDIDATE HAS TO FILE PAPERWORK,
SIGNATURES, AND EVERY SINGLE
PRIMARY STATE AND EVERY STATE IS
DIFFERENT SO STARTING ON
NOVEMBER 8TH, ALABAMA STARTS AND
SO THESE DEMOCRATS THAT ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE RUMORS ABOUT
BLOOMBERG AND MICHELLE OBAMA
WHICH I DOUBT, ALL OF THEM HAVE
TO START FILING ALL OF THESE
DOCUMENTS IN NOVEMBER.
THIS IS JUST ONE CALENDAR.
YOU CAN SEE ALL OF THE DATES
FILLED IN, STARTING IN DECEMBER.
EVERY SINGLE DAY LEADING UP TO
CHRISTMAS IS A DAY PRACTICALLY
THAT THESE DEADLINES COME UP
ABOUT IT SO ALL THESE RUMORS
ABOUT BLOOMBERG, MICHELLE OBAMA,
I THINK, OBVIOUSLY, IT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH TO DO.
THERE'S SO MUCH WORK THAT GOES
INTO THIS AND AS SUCH UPHEAVAL
THAT I HIGHLY, HIGHLY DOUBT
THIS.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU ANALYZE
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING.
BREAKING NEWS, PELOSI DOESN'T
HAVE THE VOTES TO HAVE AN
OFFICIAL IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY AND
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT THOSE
NEARLY 40 DEMOCRATS THAT ARE IN
DISTRICTS DONALD TRUMP WON, THEY
CAN'T BE TOO HAPPY WITH THIS
RIDICULOUS NO REASON IMPEACHMENT
JUST BECAUSE WE WANT TO DO IT,
WE DON'T LIKE IT.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
DONE A GOOD JOB AS OF LATE AND
WHAT I THINK HE SHOULD DO MORE
OF WHICH IS PLAYED TO THE VICTIM
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
TALK ABOUT THE BIG PICTURE.
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT NOTHING
IS GOING TO GET DONE BECAUSE OF
THIS PARTISAN JOB THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING.
YOU KNOW, THE OTHER THING IS,
THESE DEMOCRATS HAVE PLAYED IT
ALL WRONG.
THEY ARE GOING FOR A CONVICTION
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE AND I THINK
THE REPUBLICANS SHOULD REMIND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OF THAT AND
THEN, LOOK, I THINK THE
WHITE HOUSE AT THE OTHER DAY.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO TAKE A
VOTE ON IMPEACHMENT, THEY WANT
TO GIVE REPUBLICANS A SUBPOENA
POWER AS WELL, THEN GO AHEAD AND
DO IT.
I THINK THAT MESSAGE, ALTHOUGH
YOU SET IT MANY TIMES BECAUSE
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE SAID IT MANY
TIMES, I THINK IT HAS TO BE
REPEATED OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
LET THE PRESIDENT PLAYED THE
VICTIM AND TALK ABOUT THE BIG
PICTURE WITH WHAT HE SEES FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
DOING LAWRENCE, YOU ARE TALKING
TO THE DEMOCRATS THERE AND
THERE'S THIS HUGE APPETITE FOR,
AFTER THREE YEARS, THE
DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS, THEY
HAVEN'T DONE A THING.
IS THERE AN APPETITE FOR NOW
ANOTHER IMPEACHMENT PUSHED BY
THEM?
AMONG DEMOCRATS?
>> I THINK WE ARE THE APPETITE,
PERIOD.
I'M DRIVING ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND I'VE COMPARED TRUMP
RALLIES.
ALL THE SUPPORTERS OF THE OTHER
CANDIDATES AND IT DOESN'T EVEN
COME EVEN CLOSE TO THAT.
SO I THINK THE REASON WHY THEY
ARE ASKING FOR MICHELLE OBAMA OR
SOMEONE LIKE BLOOMBERG IS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW AND BIDEN IS
STARTING TO LOOK LIKE A FAILURE
RIGHT NOW WITH THE HUNTER BIDEN
STUFF.
YOU KNOW, HE ADMITTED TODAY THAT
HE DOESN'T BELIEVE HE WOULD'VE
GOTTEN A JOB IF HE DIDN'T HAVE
THE LAST NAME BIDEN AND I THINK
THE AVERAGE DAY PERSON IS TIRED
OF THE CORRUPTION, THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE WELL CONNECTED, AND I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO AFFECT THE
NEXT ELECTION WHEN THEY COME OUT
TO VOTE.
>> Sean: AND I NEVER TALKED